thanks to indochino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me
look fly the whole point is to put the
defendant through a difficult painful
experience and
even if cases fail in lower courts as
they often do
the plaintiffs can find ways to extend
them through intensive discovery
requests
depositions and appeals that drain the
target's time and resources
john oliver did an entire episode about
some arcane procedural law
you better believe i'm gonna respond
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because john oliver spent an
entire episode
talking about a lawsuit filed against
him by murray energy and its ceo
bob murray and all of the implications
that stem from
these kind of speech stifling lawsuits
so let's
dig in deep to this episode of john
oliver and see if it actually holds
water or not
the background here is that in 2017 john
oliver did an episode about a few coal
companies owned by a man named bob
murray
before that episode aired murray and his
companies sent john oliver a cease and
desist letter
and after the episode aired bob murray
filed suit for defamation
mr murray alleged that john oliver and
his show had defamed him
comedian john oliver is the target of a
lawsuit by one of the country's largest
privately owned coal companies
oliver strongly criticized murray energy
corporation and ceo robert murray sunday
on his hbo show bob had apparently never
heard of the
streisand effect murray sued john oliver
and hbo
in west virginia state court which is
important for reasons that we'll discuss
in just a moment the case was in
litigation for two years but at the
trial
court level it was decided in oliver and
hbo's favor at the motion to dismiss
state meaning that
no evidence was necessary the court
could look at the complaint itself
and determine that bob murray's claims
held no water it was no surprise when
the case was dismissed by the west
virginia judge who heard it last
february and at that point we figured
this whole saga was over right
well wrong after the motion to dismiss
was granted
bob murray appealed and the case was
waiting for
a decision from the court of appeal in
the interim murray energy declared
bankruptcy
and apparently dropped the appeal
effectively handing the overall win
to john oliver so effectively john
oliver won at both the trial level
and at the appellate level because bob
murray gave up the appeal
the thing is this was sort of a pyrrhic
victory because
john oliver claims that hbo spent over
200 000
on their legal defense some of that was
paid for by
insurance and now his insurance premiums
have effectively tripled despite the
fact that hbo was
effectively victorious in this suit to
reiterate we
won this case now of course this is just
one side of this debate this is coming
from
john oliver directly but the story
definitely rings true
there would have been extensive
litigation costs here
initially the case was filed in west
virginia state court
that is actually where bob murray sued
us despite the fact that neither he
nor i live there then hbo and john
oliver did what's called a removal
where the case is transferred from the
state court to the federal court in west
virginia
for technical reasons that was remanded
back to the state court case
where the state court judge held in
john oliver's favor on all counts as a
matter of law
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
do effectively one of the reasons
federal courts exist in the first place
is to be able to adjudicate matters
between people that
are not residents of the state where
the court case was filed and it also
makes sense that
certain types of insurance would cover
some but perhaps not
all of the attorneys fees that were
raised during the course of that
litigation
and really 200 000 for this kind of
litigation
might even be on the low end frankly we
did wonder
what was the point of him putting us
through all of this
in the first place well i would argue
it's because winning the case
was never really his goal but what is
especially interesting from my
perspective
is that this most recent john oliver
episode hinges on something called a
slap suit
and a law that is in response to those
called an anti-slap
law so what is a slapsuit and why do
anti-slap laws
exist and is john oliver right that we
need
a federal anti-slap law well i'm so glad
you asked
first a little background about the
american legal system
i'm gonna let you in on a secret about
lawsuits
so come in close now a little bit closer
lawsuits are really expensive and
lawyers
are also really expensive one of the
things about the
american judicial system is that we have
what's called the american rule where
you pay for your own attorney whether
you win or lose
the british rule in contrast is where
the winner of the lawsuit
gets their attorney's fees back
effectively as damages against
the party that lost the lawsuit so under
the british system if you're the
plaintiff and you win your lawsuit
then you get to recover your attorney's
fees that you paid and if you're a
defendant that effectively
defends against an unmeritorious
plaintiff's
suit then you get your attorney's fees
from the plaintiff
now i actually don't particularly like
the american rule if i could change one
thing about the american system
it might be the fact that you have to
pay generally speaking
for your own attorney win or lose it
leads to
plaintiffs who should file suit but
don't because they're worried about
even if they win the lawsuit they won't
get enough to pay for their attorney's
fees it can be very very expensive and
it also leads to
defendants who settle cases when they
really
shouldn't because they are worried about
how much they're going to have to pay in
attorney's fees
even if they successfully defend against
a plaintiff and often this leads to what
are called nuisance value suits where
defendants just
simply settle to avoid having to pay
their own attorneys
legislatures know that lawsuits are
really expensive legislators are often
made up
of lots of lots of attorneys so they
know in particular
how expensive lawsuits can be so both
slap suits
and anti-slap laws are intertwined with
the fact that sometimes lawsuits can be
very very expensive
a slap suit is a strategic lawsuit
against public participation in other
words
is a lawsuit that is filed to try to
stifle someone's
public participation generally speaking
their ability to
freely discuss things in the world
because the first amendment gives you a
right to
make certain kinds of speech and it
prevents the government from
intervening in that kind of speech and
the judicial system is effectively a
branch of the government so a slap suit
is where someone
files a lawsuit to try and stifle
someone to
force them to incur a huge amount of
attorney's fees
just having to defend a lawsuit that
doesn't have any merit to it the
quintessential example
of a slap suit is filing a defamation
case against someone
where they have just simply given their
opinion about something someone leaves a
yelp review and you sue them for
defamation when
either what they said is true or it's
just a matter of opinion which cannot be
the basis
for defamation so at base a slap suit is
a lawsuit that is meant to
punish someone for exercising their free
speech rights
an anti-slap law generally allows a
defendant to fight back against an
unmeritorious
lawsuit that's just trying to stifle
their free speech by number one
allowing them to dismiss the lawsuit
very early
and number two recouping their fees that
they incurred from their attorneys in
fighting back against that suit
now the way that an anti-slap law does
this is
particularly interesting from my
perspective as a litigator and trial
lawyer
an anti-slap allows the defendant to
shift the burden to the plaintiff
early on in the case to provide some
evidence this is called a
requiring the plaintiff to prove a prima
facie case
now what happens normally in a lawsuit
is that the plaintiff
starts the lawsuit by filing something
called a complaint the complaint is a
pretty bare-bones document
the standard is what's called notice
pleading you just have to
put the defendant on notice of the
general thing that you
are alleging the court will assume that
all of the allegations in that complaint
are absolutely true whatever the
plaintiff said
is true and contrary to what you see on
tv
we don't want judges or the court system
to
get rid of all lawsuits at this very
early stage for lack of
evidence i see that on tv all the time
oh there's no evidence in this complaint
therefore it has to be dismissed
that's not how it works the court will
assume everything that the plaintiff
said
is true at the time of filing because
sometimes
you need to gather evidence during the
course of the lawsuit you might not have
all of the evidence when you
start your particular lawsuit but by the
same token
the plaintiff's complaint which contains
a bunch of allegations it's
is effectively the plaintiff's own story
isn't evidence
contrary to what you might have heard on
the internet plaintiff's complaint
is not something that they can introduce
into evidence
now sometimes you can attach evidence to
the complaints like a contract for
example that might be an exhibit to the
complaint
but the complaint itself and the
allegations that it contains aren't
evidence
so when a defendant files what's called
an anti-slap
motion it puts a small burden on the
plaintiff
it requires the plaintiff to present
evidence to the court
just the bare minimum of evidence
necessary
to raise the inference that the
plaintiff could be right this is called
the
prima facie case if the plaintiff can't
put forth that evidence
then the suit is dismissed and the
defendant gets to recover their
attorneys fees that they incurred in
defending that suit
so procedurally here's how most
anti-slap laws work
first the defendant makes the motion and
the defendant bears the burden
they have to prove that the allegations
that the plaintiff has made
relate to free speech and that the suit
itself
might be hindering of the defendant's
free speech rights
if the defendant meets that burden then
the burden shifts then the plaintiff
must make their prima facie case
by putting forward competent evidence
remember they can get away with
filing a lawsuit at the pleading stage
without any evidence whatsoever
and generally that'll take you all the
way through to discovery but if an
anti-slap is implicated then at that
point the plaintiff must
put forward just a little bit of
evidence to prove their primo fascia
case
now detractors of anti-slap laws argue
that this is
unfair for some plaintiffs that it
creates a burden on plaintiffs that
doesn't really
exist in other situations and why are
speech-related suits worthy of an
exception
to the general rule that everyone just
pays their
own attorney's fees why not either make
that the rule in all cases or get rid of
that particular requirement
when it comes to slapsticks and murray
is not alone in seemingly
using lawsuits to punish and intimidate
his critics in fact
one of his good friends has openly
called for changes that would make it
easier to file them
i'm going to open up our libel laws so
when they write
purposely negative and horrible and
false articles
we can sue them and win lots of money so
we're going to open up those libel laws
folks
and we're going to have people sue you
like you never got sued before
now i have covered anti-slap laws on
this channel before this is actually an
issue that i have litigated many times
in real life
and it's interesting that john oliver
argued that president trump who is
a friend of bob murray has filed slap
suits
in the past which is arguably true but
it's also the case that president trump
has
greatly benefited from anti-slap laws as
well
in fact president trump used an
anti-slapp law recently to his advantage
when he recovered a huge amount of
attorneys fees
you might recall that stormy daniels
filed suit against the president for
defamation
and in that suit stormy daniels alleged
that she had an affair with the
president the president
tweeted in response a total con job
playing the fake news media for fools
but they know it exclamation point
now according to stormy daniels she
claimed that
president trump meant to convey that she
was a liar that she could not be trusted
and she was falsely complaining about
crimes that never happened
and on the basis of president trump's
tweet stormy daniels claimed that that
was
false and defamatory in defamation per
se
stormy daniels lost that lawsuit because
of an anti-slap motion by president
trump's legal team
and she ended up being on the hook for
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
attorneys fees that president trump
incurred in defending that suit
similarly another defamation suit that
has raised some eyebrows for slap and
anti-slap issues
is devin nunes's suit against the
twitter handle of the person that's
claiming to be the cow
of devin nunes claiming that that
twitter account
was being defamatory and mean to uh mr
nunez
some have speculated that nunes filed
suit in virginia specifically to avoid
california's very robust anti-slap laws
pretty much everyone from judges to
legal scholars agrees that slap suits
are a scourge
that is why 30 states have some form of
anti-slap laws
john oliver is absolutely right that
only 30 states have adopted some form of
anti-slap
laws this can be a big issue where
videos and tv broadcasts are
national and often multiple states have
jurisdiction
over the particular claim so what we see
often is a clever plaintiff can
venue shop or jurisdiction shop to get a
jurisdiction that is
more favorable to that particular
plaintiff it's an open question whether
federal courts will even
apply a state-based anti-slap law even
if the state has an anti-slap law
well we reached out to murray last week
to review the details that we plan to
include in this piece he wrote a letter
back
saying we were falsely vilifying him
launching scoreless attacks
and arguing that none of his lawsuits
are slap suits which they
absolutely are so was john oliver right
that
bob murray's suit was a meritless slap
suit well
probably the trial judge threw out
murray's case and the court of appeal
probably would have done the same thing
but john oliver understandably doesn't
exactly put murray's argument in the
best light possible
john oliver implies that murray's entire
claim was predicated on calling him a
geriatric dr
evil and that they had a staff member
dress up as a squirrel and
tell bob to eat i actually don't don't
even remember that happening can we just
quickly can we just for a moment check
the tape
it's made out too
fair enough my mistake we did it it's
funny the things you forget
and while that's absolutely true and
that did form part of the allegations
that's not everything that murray
actually complained about in the lawsuit
itself
murray also claimed that john oliver
quote deliberately omitted the facts
plaintiffs provided regarding the
crandall canyon mine incident
intentionally falsely and outrageously
conveyed that mr murray has no evidence
to support his statements that an
earthquake caused the tragedy
reinforced the impression he gave his
audience that mr murray lied about the
cause of the mind collapse and had no
evidence to support his position
with other thinly veiled implications
that mr murray is a liar in general
and quote falsely insinuated that
plaintiffs and mr murray
disregarded the well-being of their
employees
those are direct quotes from bob
murray's complaint
so it's perhaps not as cut and dry as
john oliver made it out to seem
but this is not exactly a close case
here in west virginia the essential
elements for defamation are
one defamatory statements two
non-privileged communication to a third
party
three falsity four reference to the
plaintiff
five fault and six resulting injury
these are
pretty standard requirements for
defamation and under west virginia law
defamation requires a provably false
assertion of
fact the fourth circuit has said that
where it is clear that a speaker is
expressing only
quote a subjective view an
interpretation a theory conjecture or
surmise
rather than a claim to be in possession
of objectively verifiable false facts
then that speech receives full
constitutional protection
in other words opinion and rhetorical
hyperbole
do not qualify as defamation and courts
have used this principle to shelter
things like
vigorous epithets rhetorical hyperboles
and other
quote loose figurative language that
cannot reasonably be understood to
convey facts about someone
if we discuss bob murray in a way no
reasonable person could construe as
factual
we could say whatever the [ __ ] we like
so as the west virginia court recognized
john oliver was one making an argument
two making
jokes and three actually reporting
on various things that actually happened
and
of course generally jokes and satirical
references are not considered false
statements of fact and on top of that
because murray was a public figure he
would have had to prove that john oliver
made the statement showing that
john oliver knew they were false this is
sometimes called the actual malice
standard
but that's a really misleading term of
art basically it's just
the mental state required to prove
defamation when you're dealing with a
public figure
and additionally john oliver relied on
the west virginia
fair report privilege which shields the
media from liability for their coverage
of any official government action or
proceeding
provided the report is accurate complete
and or
a fair abridgement of the occurrence
that was reported murray's mind collapse
was the subject of a governmental
investigation
and john oliver was reporting on that
governmental investigation now of course
there is a hilarious
coda to this whole affair and john
oliver kind of gets the last laugh here
i actually have some bad news and some
good news for you the bad news is
the last two years have honestly just
been too exhausting so
i'm afraid i am not going to say
anything more about bob murray tonight
the good news is why would i when i can
simply
sing it instead even though he'll
threaten
legal armageddon we have just one
tiny thing to say for the
last third of the entire episode john
oliver does a
song and dance about all of these
terrible things that they accuse
bob murray of doing oliver spends
roughly 10 minutes saying every
possible horrible thing that they could
against bob murray and i got a ton of
questions from all of the legal eagles
out there who were wondering if
john oliver was going to subject himself
to a lawsuit again for saying false
things about bob murray
well what you might not have caught is
that at the beginning of that song and
dance routine
uh oliver says that if they say things
that are so ridiculous that no one could
believe them that it
won't qualify as defamation and that is
absolutely right hyperbole
can't really be the subject of a
defamation suit
and so that's the reason that oliver
says all of these
insanely ridiculous things about bob
murray and
sings and dances about it hey what's the
big idea weezy protected speech to tell
bob murray to each
[ __ ] murray but the thing is murray
could always
sue again because there is no national
anti-slap law
we badly need effective anti-slap laws
nationwide to deter powerful people like
bob murray
from using the courts to shut down
people's legitimate descent
he could file suit in west virginia
again and
oliver could be subjected to another
defamation suit
because as oliver probably rightly
points out
murray never wanted to win the lawsuit
he just wanted to inflict
pain against john oliver and hbo now i
will say if you're going to do a victory
dance in the middle of times square like
john oliver
you're going to want to wear a perfectly
custom tailored suit
and indochino could probably put
together a sequin number just like john
oliver
if you're looking for a custom slim cut
suit that is shockingly affordable
i can't recommend indochino highly
enough all of my suits are now custom
made by indochino including
this gray two-button suit that i'm
wearing right now which was custom-made
just for me
see the secret to a great suit is all
about the fit i'm a reasonably athletic
guy and i can never buy suits off the
rack
it either doesn't fit or it costs a
fortune to have a tailor fix it for me
but with indochino you can send in your
measurements online or you can go to one
of their stores and have a stylist take
your measurements for you
i made an appointment i went to a store
in person and had a stylist work with me
for over 90 minutes when i went in for
the first time
my personal stylist took my measurements
and a couple of weeks later i got the
best fitting suit of my entire life it
was perfect
right out of the box indochino will make
you a fully custom tailored suit
specifically for you for
less than 400 and the best part is they
still use the best materials like super
140s wool
in fact if you use the promo code legal
eagle at checkout you can get any
premium indochino suit for only 359
dollars i will never get an off the rack
suit again and once you try it neither
will you
legal eagles can get any premium
indochino suit for just 359 when you
enter the promo code legal eagle at
checkout
or if you click on the link in the
description clicking on that link really
helps out this channel that's
indochino.com
promo code legaleagle for the best
custom suit of your entire life
so do you agree with my analysis do you
think we should have nationwide
anti-slap laws or we should just scrap
them all together
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist of all of my
other real law reviews including things
like the
impeachment hearings where i will see
you in court